you worked with Laurence Fishburne on
passengers and and I'm just curious I've
always thought he's one of he's just I
love that guy
I really do love that guy yeah had the
privilege to meet him a bunch of times
but he's such a lovely person did he was
it fun to work with him I would think a
baby I loved working with I'm a huge fan
of Laurence Fishburne I mean ever since
you know watching the matrix and and
yeah you know even before that but the
matrix I think like was really a movie
for him that his life changed
drastically and right and he and I were
discussing a little bit just sort of
this thing that can happen where a movie
can come out and you know with me it was
probably like guardians of the galaxy of
Jurassic world when they came out it's
something a little bit of there were
minor changes in the world around me
that like made my life much different
right and and we were kind of bonding
over those things and one of the things
I said was you know I in this day and
age with people with a cell phone the
people want to take pictures a lot you
know and and that can become a lot and
so I when I go out it's different cuz I
don't want to let anybody down you know
you seem like a people pleaser you want
to make people happy yeah but when
everyone wants a photo it can be tough
and he said if you're waiting for
somebody to give you permission I'm
giving you permission and all you have
to say is not today baby I was like
warrants I don't think I could say not
today maybe now like you and have it be
really cool and smooth yeah I would look
like an idiot yeah it's like just try it
I was like not today baby doesn't burn
can do that yeah you can't do that I
can't do that no Lawrence can do that
yeah yeah let's get away with he's an
awesome dude
he he's really cool
you